hi I'm Nikki Glaser and I'm gonna answer
the internet would you rather everyone
be naked all the time or clothed all the
time full all the time I guess how are
we gonna have sex naked all the time
I think you'd get used to it I think
it's like when a bad smell you bet you
spoof oh no like someone's just dirty
dick hanging in your face like all the
time well you know what it'd be nice you
just know what you're getting before you
go in and so much of my anxiety around
hooking up is like what are their dick
gonna be like like not that it needs to
be big but what if it's just like a
weird dick and then you would just know
yeah balls start follows you can ignore
but like the dick it's just like
sometimes it can be so frightening and I
know [ __ ] can be the same way so yes
I would like to make it stand by it is
it weird for a guy to prefer Lube hand
jobs over [ __ ] um no it is not weird
because you like you probably just like
more eye contact and maybe just me to
sing you a song you liked it you liked
probably [ __ ] because I don't have a
listen I don't have a lot of [ __ ]
confidence but definitely not a lot I've
had less practice with hand jobs than
[ __ ] so probably a err on the side
of [ __ ] seems like it's just be a
faster thing and nothing like a guy
being like this isn't good like I don't
even want to if you're gonna make the
face of this isn't good I don't want to
be able to see it you know yeah what do
you have oh stop masturbating yes would
you stop macerating at every girl if
every guy you jerked off to knew you
were doing it no I would masturbate way
more way more way more way more and that
would be the Ivan that would inspire me
to masturbate if I knew that a guy's ear
would itch and he would know because
that would be a way to let a guy know
you like them just like another way to
let it go I know you like them is if you
tell them that you had
REME about them protip dream about you
it doesn't have to be a sexual dream
just any dream it makes them realize
that you're thinking about them
subconsciously yeah and then touch your
hair when you do it like I had a dream
about you last night great way to make a
guy I know you like because I'm always
I'm always looking for ways to like let
guys know I like them cuz you're
supposed to as a girl just like smile
and like and that is humiliating
I'd rather talk about you on a podcast
that I hope you hear I wouldn't I'm not
saying I wouldn't I'm six cuz sometimes
you're masturbating and someone just
like in your fantasy just like walks in
the room and you're like what are you
doing here yeah I wouldn't mind I'd want
him to have that and be like I was in
someone's jerk-off fantasy today that
would be like a nice little feather in
your cap would you count to 1 million
for a million dollars you are locked in
an empty room until you're finished I
would have to add up how long that takes
and I think it's gonna take a really
long time and I already I don't need
more money so no I don't I don't want
for anything no but it's not because I
am a cheap [ __ ] like I don't need like
luxury if I need it if I had liked
handbags and nice clothing and expensive
trips I would be wantin a lot but I just
find that I don't I don't need that much
ok if you had to move to a different to
waste that long of your life counting to
a million I want to live if you had to
move it to a different place on the body
where would you put the vagina maybe
like slightly back I don't know what I
would keep it down there but maybe like
put it at a different angle yeah oh yeah
I move it up I'd move it up but no I'd
move it up because guys already think
it's like up anyway guys like think the
hole goes like right here like so I
would just
it should be it should be I'd move it up
if every time you finished it sex a song
played what song would you want it to be
this is tough
every time I mean I probably like
crushed by Dave Matthews because as a
kid not a kid but like at yeah I guess
kid when I was 16 or 17 like all I
wanted to do was have sex to the song
crush by Dave Matthews with Dave
Matthews while it was playing so it's
never gonna happen but I guess I could
just listen to it after sex every time
for the rest of my life because I had to
pick an answer would you rather have to
tell your mom everything sexually you've
ever done or have to show her your
entire porn history I've done both of
these because she's watching my special
so she knows my porn history because
that's what I talk about in my special
bangin and I also say pretty much
everything sexual I've ever done I the
other day she goes why did you you said
you blew him everyone knows that now
Nick and I go what okay
what's gonna what's the worst thing that
could happen that everyone knows I blew
someone she was like I don't know maybe
he doesn't want people knowing that and
I go okay so then what happens and she's
like it's just not nice I'm like it's
not like I blew a guy I get to and he
ghosted me sorry I get to talk about it
so my mom knows way too much I feel bad
almost almost it's jerking off to nudes
of a girl who has died weird or a nice
nice tribute total it's a little weird
but I've done it too when I the first
guy I was ever like it was Dave Matthews
and then two men who have like
significantly influenced who I've been
into the rest of my life Dave Matthews
and John FK jr. and I only knew about
him after his plane crash I didn't know
about this guy before until he was on
Time magazine like a memorial issue that
my parents got and I stole it and tore
out pictures from like and put them on
my wall of a dead what's like so into
him and and I didn't know about him till
he died
so still still thinking about him
tribute never forget you John John John
and
order for you to live you have to kill a
blind child who has the greatest voice
of our generation whoever wrote this
will you please write for me for the
roast I don't know who said that one and
that's so funny in order for you to live
you have to kill a blind child I mean
why does it have to be blind what makes
it worse to kill or doesn't
oh my god oh you would know I acted ok
do I have to kill him myself at oh I
don't think I could live then so I'd
probably die but if it was like a
situation where you press a button and a
blind kid with a great voice dies
somewhere in the world
drumroll please I did the button would
you date your dream girl if for two days
every week she had to dress like if he
would you'd rate your dream guy if for
two days every week your choice of the
week or days oh thank you
she had to dress like a Juggalo he had
to dress like a Juggalo yeah that's
hilarious that is one time I dared my
ex-boyfriend for a month to wear a just
gigantic case on his phone that was
loose rubber minion he doesn't leave the
minions I've never seen the minions I
just saw the case I was like kid if you
wore that on your phone from month I'll
pay $500 but when people ask you can't
say it's a prank you have to say I'm a
minion man and he did it he [ __ ] did
it
yeah it made me love him so much because
what a weird thing and he had just got a
new job so he is at work and had to like
his boss was like and he didn't tell
anyone and he went home and his sister
was like what is going on with that that
case is so not you and he just was like
I'm just like a minion man man I'm into
them and she goes something's going on
here and I'm gonna find out what it is
but yeah you got five hundred dollars
yeah
would you rather suck one dick for
$50,000 or get $1,000 for every dick you
sucked 50,000 easy I'm not gonna suck
fifty one dicks
but one dick and I get 50,000 so I'll
just save that infinity
there's no limit Oh for the rest of my
life that would be a nice little bonus
okay you just sold me I'm going one dick
per $1,000 and it's just like a nice
like extra spending cash that's so fun
it would be like a birthday gift for my
friends I'd be like you want $1,000 I'll
go suck that guy's dick
happy birthday Anja that's such a good
idea okay would you rather be an
extremely good-looking paralyzed person
or a hideous fully functioning person
extremely good-looking paralyzed I'm so
vapid so vapid but yeah I'd be rolling
around town looking hot as [ __ ] would
you rather be filthy rich in 1900 or
poor now oh that is a good question
filthy rich in 1900 yeah because I know
but like also if it's me and I have to
go back there I'm gonna realize oh this
sucks compared to but when you're just
living there that's all you know and
you're like this is [ __ ] awesome so
it would be like being filthy rich now
you wouldn't know the difference would
you rather everyone in your girlfriend's
boyfriend's office want to [ __ ] him or
nobody want to what you guys know the
answer to this I want everyone to want
to [ __ ] him and possibly have the chance
Dale and then tell me about it if you
could be the master at one of the four
bases of sex but you'd already have to
be below but you'd have to be below
average at every other base which one
would you choose
um I think I would be the master of
sucking dick because if you're below
average at [ __ ] that means I'm
probably already there and I'm doing a
good job like I don't think I'm probably
that's probably art yeah I'd liked
[ __ ]
I think below average like I just like
to lay back and get it that's got to be
below average and it's just how I enjoy
it so then I'm greatest lucky Nick great
I would love that to happen is there
something that makes you automatically
swipe right on tinder so many
things number one a guy in a picture
from a wedding that he went to and
probably ruined cuz he got too drunk but
it's like before that happened and he
has like a black-and-white photo of
himself that he thinks looks really cool
but he's doing some kind of signature
dance move on the dance were they like
the worm or something he has a beer
stain on his shirt and it's like that
guy thinks he's like I'm the life of the
party but it's like you're the liability
of the party and no one likes you and
you're not fun that or anything about
whiskey and tacos the bite weight swiped
right I'm doing swipe left
who cares about right swipe left okay
swipe left okay so I'm Adam Atta Kalia
swipe light left if you have some dance
the picture where you're doing the worm
because I don't no one wants a guy that
does the worm you've convinced yourself
that people enjoy that no one does
and you always want all the attention to
be on you and I can't take that because
I want it and then I and then oh yeah
you mentioned anything about whiskey or
tacos because it's like I get it you're
white and you don't have an identity
outside of food and drink that everyone
likes
everyone likes that so that sucks also
anything that's like just don't write
anything can I tell the guys that don't
stop right if a girl doesn't want to
[ __ ] you based on your looks nothing you
say is gonna change her mind literally
it's only gonna hurt you it's only gonna
hurt you no girl has ever been swiping
left on a guy and the ghost oh wait as
mom says he's a catch and it's like it
never happened it's not gonna save you
so don't write anything cuz it's only
[ __ ] walking you to write anything what
was better ages 8 to 18 or ages 18 to 28
I mean I think oh boy 8 to 18 I had a
really good time in high school and I
got a I caught an eating disorder at 18
so this was like both that this was like
when I could eat freely and not think
about every calorie I was eating uh to
eat pizza but with unbridled and like
just cereal bowl after cereal bowl
without being like I am a girl I eat
myself ah freedom yeah
8 to 18 [ __ ] marry marry [ __ ] kill I
love how they had to like reword it
because of copyright marry [ __ ] kill
Brad Pitt Matthew McConaughey
Matthew McConaughey Channing Tatum [ __ ]
Brad Pitt Mary Channing Tatum kill
Matthew McConaughey I always feel bad
about killing I don't want to kill
anyone
but he's lit he's lived a pretty good
life yeah he said that most like you
know illustrious career I guess what
would you choose if you could only have
one for the rest of your life
guys going down and make blow jobs so
eating out regular sex or anal great
question
God okay so it and you can't use
anything on any other other of the parts
so you can't be like having sex but like
put something in your ass I mean you got
to go vagina but I'm not happy about it
boys I'm not happy about it